Here's the function poker.
What am I going to do to change this to handle ties?
It seems like it might be complicated.
We didn't talk about ties here at all.
The max function doesn't do anything about ties.
How are we going to handle that?
Well, here's my suggestion for how to handle it.
I'm just going to say we had the right idea here
that we want to go through all the hands, and we want to
compare them using hand_rank.
But instead of returning the one maximum,
let's invent a new function called allmax
that returns a collection--it could be a set or a list--of all the maximums.
And now let's have you write the function allmax.
It takes an input, which is a list or something else that you can iterate over,
and Python uses the word "iterable" to refer to that.
And it optionally takes a keyword argument just the way that max did.
Max can take a key or not.
And what we want to do is return, and let's make a commitment
and say we're going to return a list
of all the items in the iterable
that are equal to the max of the iterable.